[Applaudissements]
est une barrière contre la dictature il
se pose comme quelqu'un qui garantit la
stabilité démocratique et la stabilité
républicaine dans un moment de menace
d'extrême droite
[Musique]
Luna est un homme du peuple qui a décidé
de sortir le peuple de la famille
[Musique]
le meilleur leader du peuple brésilien
destiné à devenir un leader mondial
de la politique
un symbole de progrès des dialogues de
paix
[Musique]
c'est la seconde chance pour le Brésil
de se réconcilier avec lui-même
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le 30 octobre 2022 Luis ignaccio Lula da
Silva a été élu pour la troisième fois
président du Brésil une victoire
historique pour un candidat des gélus
président lié à 20 ans une revanche
éclatante pour un homme qui a survécu un
cancer a perdu la plupart de ses proches
et a été victime d'un procès politique
qui lui a valu 580 jours de prison avant
d'être totalement blanchi par la justice
un destin incroyable pour quelqu'un dont
la vie épouse étroitement l'histoire de
son pays depuis sa naissance en 1945
dans le plus grand des nuances
[Applaudissements]
la maison vivait là était une maison
typique du Nord-Est
une maison avec juste un toit et un sol
en terre battue
au même endroit une maison où il n'y a
pas de sanitaire une maison où on ne
peut rien planter parce qu'il n'y a pas
d'eau pour pouvoir cultiver quoi que ce
soit
il vient d'une sous-classe la classe de
la famine il appartient à la classe qui
meurt de faim ce qui ne peuvent pas même
s'ils le veulent devenir agriculteur
c'est encore en dessous
une enfance
tragiquement brésilienne dans le sens où
il n'a pas de figure du père c'est une
mère qui élève plusieurs frères et
soeurs certaines de ses frères et sœurs
n'ont pas survécu parce que les maladies
prédominaires pour les bébés c'est très
dur de s'alimenter les conditions
d'hygiène étaient limitées il est né
dans un monde où on n'était pas
certaines vivre jusqu'à ses deux ans
[Musique]
Lula perd en effet deux de ses frères et
sœurs mourant de fin la famille migrant
1952 vers la grande ville de Sao Paulo
c'est exode rural touche alors des
millions de Brésiliens
il vient avec sa mère ils sont huit
enfants Lola est le septième
il arrive très jeune il a 7 ans et il
doit déjà travailler il a été tireur de
chaussures puis petite main dans un
pressings
toujours qu'il était tellement petit que
quand il livrait les vestes il devait
lever le bras car il était plus petit
qu'une veste d'adultes
à l'âge de 7 ans
il a ses souvenir d'une enfance pauvre
dont il parle sans ressentiment
il en parle comme d'une expérience de
vie très forte et c'est un moyen pour
lui de se connecter avec les personnes
qui vivent encore ça au Brésil
à 14 ans Lula entre à l'usine Volkswagen
où il devient tourneur Fraser il va être
touché dans sa chair par la dureté des
conditions de travail il perd un doigt
emporté par une machine
[Musique]
a été organisé par l'entreprise un
système de répression contre
l'engagement politique des travailleurs
le dirigeant le responsable de cette
répression était un commandant d'un camp
de concentration en Allemagne
il a été recruté pour venir au Brésil
faire ce travail de répression
[Musique]
en 1964 la répression se durcit un peu
plus
l'armée fait un coup d'état les chars
sont dans la rue et la dictature
militaire s'installe pour 21 ans
[Musique]
Lula est déjà syndiquée mais sa priorité
n'est pas de combattre la dictature il
veut avant tout fonder une famille
mais sa jeune épouse Maria me rend
couche ainsi que son bébé par manque de
soin
pour surmonter son chagrin Lula
s'investit alors dans le puissant
syndicat de la métallurgie dont il
devient l'un des principaux négociateurs
[Musique]
c'est l'histoire des Brésiliens qui se
réorganise en fonction de
l'industrialisation du pays dans les
années 60-70 et c'est cette
industrialisation qui crée aussi une
nouvelle forme de faire de la politique
au niveau des syndicats des mouvements
sociaux qui se sont forgés pendant la
dictature militaire qui crée les
conditions pour que Lola et devienne un
acteur très compétitif
la popularité de Lula commence à se
dessiner quand il devient président du
syndicat en 1975
il redéfinit la stratégie qui est d'être
présent aux portes des usines
la force de Lula a beaucoup à voir avec
le contact du quotidien
et ses contacts
n'est pas seulement une présence
physique elle est en contact c'est un
contact humain très puissant
c'est une personnalité très attentive
aux autres très affable il conseille il
arrive à intéresser les gens car ils ne
donnent pas des cours
il dialogue il discute
pour la vie publique et qui a cette
capacité de communiquer d'écouter
d'ailleurs c'est le propre du leader
syndical l'entente et la négociation
[Applaudissements]
mais malgré ses qualités de médiateur
Lula leaders syndical n'obtient pas
toujours gain de cause loin de là à
cette époque la confrontation avec le
régime est très dur
Lula conduit plusieurs grèves pour une
amélioration des conditions de travail
pour une augmentation des salaires ou
tout simplement pour le droit de faire
grève et la réponse est souvent très
violente
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ont été inculpés par la loi de sécurité
nationale
c'est la loi la plus répressive
instaurée par la dictature
[Musique]
et ses process se procès a duré des
années et à la fin il a été innocenté ce
qui montre bien que c'était une
tentative de miner de torpiller son
leadership
qu'il était déjà un leader important
[Applaudissements]
un leader important en effet qui est
capable de déplacer des dizaines de
milliers de personnes lors de ces
métiers
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
protéger par sa popularité Lula n'a
jamais été torturé ni assassiné ce qui
n'est pas le cas de nombreux autres
responsables politiques culturelles ou
syndicaux pendant ces années de plomb
la prise de risque de Lula elle commence
dès le début de sa carrière parce que
elle est sociologiquement parlante c'est
une prise de risque un homme du nord-est
qui prend un syndicat qui commence à
faire de la politique avec ce syndicat
jusqu'à aujourd'hui c'est vu comme
inacceptable par les élites brésiliennes
non seulement Lula tient tête à l'élite
brésilienne et la dictature mais il
réalise aussi ces années là son vœu le
plus cher fondé une famille avec sa
nouvelle épouse Marisa
[Musique]
ils auront quatre enfants et c'est aussi
un couple politique
maresa est une militante et sera de tous
les combats
c'est à ce moment-là que Lula acquiert
une stature internationale
[Musique]
est un syndicaliste dans les années 80
qui voyage le monde qui rencontre les
grands leaders de la sociale démocratie
européenne qui va rencontrer les leaders
syndicaux au Japon qui va rencontrer les
leader syndicaux Michigan dans
l'industrie automobile des États-Unis et
donc la trajectoire de Lula se confond
aussi avec l'insertion internationale du
Brésil du point de vue industriel
en 1980 Lula fonde le péter le Parti des
travailleurs
une manière de donner un débouché
politique à des revendications qui
dépassent depuis longtemps le cadre
syndical
il faut dire que le pays est toujours
aussi fermé la répression toujours aussi
dur les droits politiques et syndicaux
toujours aussi restreint
en 1984 il y a eu les plus grandes
manifestations politiques de l'histoire
du Brésil à partir de là la dictature
militaire a commencé sa chute il y a eu
un avant et un après
lola a été un des leaders de ce
mouvement pour des élections directes et
il est devenu un leader national c'était
une lutte syndicale au début depuis elle
s'est transformée en lutte politique
de créer quelque chose qui me donnait
pas seulement à moi
mais à toutes les personnes comme moi
l'opportunité d'avoir une place et
d'avoir une voix du père veiche et du
TER voice
est tout d'abord candidat pour être
gouverneur de l'état de Sao Paulo en
1982 mais il perd largement
[Musique]
il a été déçu car il est eu seulement
12% des votes des années
la légende raconte qu'il a été avec
Fidel Castro est au fidèle Castro lui a
dit c'est la première fois qu'un
candidat de gauche a autant de voix
continue à
luttero donne des leçons de démocratie à
Lola et ce n'est pas ce n'est pas
exactement une leçon de démocratie c'est
une leçon de persévérance
persévérant Loula le lait en effet il
est élu député fédéral en 1987
puis il se présente en 1989 à la
première élection présidentielle
organisée après le retour de la
démocratie dans le pays
[Applaudissements]
il parcourt alors le Brésil de l'eau en
large avec ce qu'il appelle ses
caravanes
[Applaudissements]
des discours durant les caravanes Lola
lui allait écouter les gens il demandait
comment va votre vie ici quels sont vos
problèmes qui y a-t-il de bons et de
mauvais de quoi et comment vivez-vous
d'ailleurs Hélène expression drôle à
propos de ça il dit que possède l'homme
une bouche et deux oreilles
pour écouter plus que pour parler
cette première candidature à l'élection
présidentielle sera un échec honorable
Lula ne se décourage pas et se
représentent encore en 1993 et encore en
[Musique]
mais il perd à nouveau car son programme
est encore perçu comme trop radical
[Musique]
si j'étais lui j'aurais abandonné mais
il n'a jamais abandonné je me souviens
que quand nous perdions une élection ou
quand la situation était mauvaise
parfois nous son équipe on se
décourageait
il était le premier à nous remotiver
même quand il perdait l'élection
c'était lui qui aurait dû être triste
mais il nous donnait du courage et en
voyant sa détermination on réagissait
aussi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le but recherché depuis tant d'années
est enfin atteint en 2002
Lula est élu dans la liesse populaire à
la présidence du plus grand pays
d'Amérique latine
c'était quelque chose d'inimaginable une
chose extraordinaire
[Musique]
je me suis ajouté j'ai posé mon visage
contre le sol et j'ai remercié Dieu car
c'était une chose incroyable
[Musique]
on craint un moment un nouveau coup
d'État mais le prédécesseur de Lula le
président Fernando Enrique kardoso va
peser de tout son poids pour assurer une
transition démocratique et lui passe
lui-même l'écharpe de président autour
du cou
mais pour une partie de l'élite le
passage entre
un monsieur un gentleman
très bien serré mondialement comme
Fernando Éric Cardo et un monsieur comme
Lula qui vient qui venait des
profondeurs du Nord-Est a été vu comme
un choc et comme une rupture dans les
traditions hiérarchiques et
aristocratiques du Brésil et donc là
Lola je pense qu'il incarne dans la
perfection les transformations sociales
du Brésil
le Brésil est un pays riche et développé
mais très inégalitaire quand Lula arrive
au pouvoir 30 millions de Brésiliens ne
mangent pas à leur faim comme dans un
pays du tiers-monde
les premières mesures du nouveau
président seront donc les programmes
d'alimentation phomé 0 fin 0 et Bolsa
Familia bourse familiale pour que la
princesse d'être le problème numéro 1 du
pays
[Musique]
son idée centrale c'est de garantir
trois assiettes de nourriture par jour à
chaque brésilien une disait déjà ça à
l'époque du syndicat il a encore dit
hier dans une interview qu'il a donné à
la télévision
de vivre mieux
juste ça il ne s'agit pas d'une
idéologie de gauche de droite ou du
centre c'est la trajectoire d'une vie
tout ce qu'il a fait pour nous les
pauvres pour les femmes pour les noirs
pour les gens des favelas
qui à l'époque du gouvernement de Lula
en ont fini avec le problème de la fin
et où là a aussi fait le plus grand
programme de logement de logement
populaire
[Musique]
ce qui manquait au Brésil surtout
c'était la justice sociale et les
gouvernements a commencé vraiment à
prendre de mesures pour réduire la
pauvreté réduire l'inégalité dans les
passer l'économie pouvait croître ou
diminuer n'importe l'inégalité
augmentait toujours et la première fois
que
l'inégalité a diminué au Brésil c'était
dans les gouvernement du pété
spécialement dans le gouvernement il
sait pour l'avoir vécu ce dont les gens
ont besoin et je crois qu'il la traduit
dans son gouvernement l'accès au crédit
pouvoir acheter des choses pouvoir
manger mieux pouvoir avoir une voiture
pouvoir laver sa voiture le week-end
dans sa maison c'est une chose que les
Brésiliens aiment beaucoup faire un
petit barbecue pour pouvoir acheter sa
petite maison avoir une qualité de vie
plus humaine plus décente
sous la présidence de Lula se sont ainsi
40 millions de Brésiliens qui vont
accéder à la petite classe moyenne ce
que l'on appellera les émergences les
émergents
un jour pendant un voyage nous étions en
train de déjeuner tous les deux
premiers
de la République
j'ai été surpris j'ai répondu non pas du
tout
et pourquoi parce qu'il faut être fou
pour vouloir être président de la
République du Brésil avec des problèmes
à récolter
pas du tout c'est formidable et
qu'est-ce qu'il y a de bien là-dedans et
bien tu peux résoudre tous les problèmes
[Musique]
un autre problème déjà brûlant il y a 20
ans que Lula va aussi tenter de résoudre
c'est la déforestation de l'Amazonie
nous avons réussi dans le gouvernement
de Lula dans lequel j'ai été ministre à
faire un plan de prévention et de
contrôle de la déforestation de
l'Amazonie ce plan a réduit la
déforestation de 83% pendant presque une
décennie il a évité de rejeter dans
l'atmosphère 5 milliards de tonnes de
CO2 il a aussi été à l'origine entre
2003 et 2008 la période où j'ai été dans
le gouvernement de la création de 80%
des terres protégées dans le monde
[Musique]
Marina Silva démissionnera tout de même
du gouvernement car elle estimait que
Lula n'allait pas assez loin en matière
d'environnement
notamment en autorisant la construction
du barrage géant de Belo Monte au nord
du pays pour l'irrigation et
l'électrification de la région
il a toujours une tension au Brésil
entre ce qu'on appelle agrobisme
l'agriculture commerciale et disons le
souci avait hormonal et tout ça mais
gouvernement de la justement a montré
que c'est possible de réconcilier une
partie du Brésil qui était comme l'Inde
et une partie qui était comme
l'Australie disons en terme
d'agriculture
[Musique]
en termes de culture aussi lola a tenté
de concilier les deux faces du Brésil en
un moment ministre un chanteur célèbre
dans le monde entier
[Musique]
le ministère de la Culture ministère
autours
de la scène
[Musique]
comme une métaphore de la politique de
Lula le Brésil blanc va donc découvrir
la musique métissée tandis que les
favelas vont découvrir la musique
classique
[Musique]
les mesures sociales du nouveau
président ne l'empêchent pas de soutenir
fortement l'économie à l'image du succès
emblématique de la vionneur National
emrar qui devient alors le quatrième
constructeur aéronautique mondial
dans la période de Lula le Brésil a eu
une croissance de
4,1% en moyenne
et la dernière année une croissance de
7,5 %
plus de 20 millions d'emplois formels
ont été créés
[Musique]
de 60 à 39 %
qui était endetté auprès du FMI est
devenu créditeur
et il est aujourd'hui une réserve
technique de 300 milliards de dollars
n'est pas d'extrême gauche
il ne l'a jamais été c'est un
négociateur
depuis l'époque du syndicat
en politique
la force du loup là vient du charisme
qu'il a avec les travailleurs mais aussi
avec les groupes dominants au Brésil
cette capacité à se mouvoir entre deux
univers extrêmement rivaux antagoniste
et à construire des ponts qui puissent
les réunir du point de vue de
l'expérience électorale et de
gouvernement c'est une habileté très
spéciale
[Musique]
cette capacité à lancer des passerelles
on la constate aussi dans un autre
secteur extrêmement sensible au Brésil
l'éducation
Lula multiplie par deux le nombre de
places d'universités et il veille à ce
qu'elle profite aussi à une population
qui en était jusque-là totalement exclue
[Musique]
dans le domaine de l'éducation le
gouvernement Lula a instauré une
politique de cotation
et des travailleurs
ont enfin eu accès à l'université
d'origine esclavagiste
n'ont pas eu de place dans l'économie
ni de place sur les bancs des
universités
ni d'accès à des services publics de
qualité
le Brésil est un pays de majorité
d'afrodescendants c'est le deuxième pays
avec la plus grande population noire
après le Nigéria donc ce serait le
deuxième pays africain au monde et cette
politique des universités elle a ouvert
un débat qui a un débat qui existe au
Brésil depuis 20 ans un débat
extraordinaire sur la place des afro
brésiliens des Brésiliens noirs dans
l'histoire et le futur du Brésil
la place des personnes d'origine
africaine dans le monde Lola va aussi la
poser à l'Assemblée générale de l'ONU
par l'intermédiaire de son ministre de
la Culture le chanteur Gilberto Gil
alors l'origine africaine du secrétaire
général kofiana et la raison pour
laquelle je l'ai invité à jouer sur
scène d'une façon très spontanée
informelle d'un instrument qui est
typique de notre héritage
africains
qui sont présents dans la culture
populaire et musicale du Brésil des
Amériques et de tant d'autres parties du
monde confirmer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
a été très significative pour son
gouvernement
pour lui personnellement
[Musique]
Lula ne se limite pas à l'ONU il
renforce le groupe des pays émergents
des briques qui regroupent le Brésil
l'Inde la Russie la Chine et l'Afrique
du Sud pour concurrencer les pays les
plus riches du G7
[Musique]
ce n'est pas que la politique extérieure
du Brésil d'une façon générale je parle
était mauvaise mais il y avait toujours
une certaine timidité il y avait on peut
pas oser faire ça on peut pas oser être
trop actif et la grande différence que
je voyais avec Lola c'est que
à cause de ce qu'il représentait c'est
qu'on pourrait avoir une politique
extérieure très active et très
affirmative
cela se ressent jusque dans l'attitude
personnelle de Lula qui ne semble pas
plus impressionné que ça de côtoyer les
grandes ce monde y compris à la Maison
Blanche
je vous donne un exemple je t'ai assis
avec lui quand on a l'air de notre
première visite officielle comme
président lui a à la Maison Blanche et
je
la voiture dans la voiture avec lui et
pour lui certaines choses tout à fait
normal il n'était ni nerveux ni
impressionné parce qu'il allait avoir
non c'était normal c'était normal
certains comme s'il était avant ici
quand il doit devait
avoir une négociation avec le président
de Volkswagen du Brésil c'est anormal
George Bush George Bush est un
républicain un homme conservateur
en peu de temps est devenu ami avec
Georges Bush beaucoup de gens ne
comprenaient pas ça il y a une réunion
au Mexique à l'intérieur du Mexique un
guadal
quand la réunion des chefs d'État des
Amériques est finie je vois qu'il reste
juste Loula et George Bush qui discute
au fond du salon
[Musique]
plus tard j'ai demandé à Lula mais en
quelle langue vous étiez en train de
parler
emportegnol il m'a répondu pour Tignol
c'est le mélange informel de portugais
d'espagnol il m'a dit mais tu es un
ignorant
on parlait espagnol donc nous parlions
ce sont des secrets de chef d'État
[Musique]
Lula est effectivement un chef d'État
apprécié de ses pères et après avoir
conquis George Bush il va séduire son
successeur lors d'un sommet du G20
restait dans toutes les mémoires
a toujours été très attentif à avoir un
rôle international majeur à s'approcher
des grandes puissances a montré qu'il
est représentait au Brésil dans les
grands cercles mondiaux parce que là
pour le coup ça changeait la perspective
de l'élite brésilienne parce que le jour
où Obama il dit
this is the même de mon sport
c'est un choc pour satellite qui ne
voulait pas reconnaître cet homme au
pouvoir et donc Lula il a toujours su
jouer dans la perfection avec ses
différentes dimensions la dimension
globale et la dimension très locale
l'intérieur du Brésil et les grands
cercles diplomatiques
et c'est comme ça que Lula finit son
deuxième mandat avec une popularité
record de 87%. une popularité à faire
rêver n'importe quel chef d'État
[Musique]
mais après demanda la Constitution
brésilienne ne lui permet pas de se
représenter
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il passe donc le flambeau à sa protéger
dilmar Rousseff élu présidente en 2010
une revanche pour cette ancienne
guerriera durement torturé sous la
dictature et un succès pour Lula qui
enracine ainsi un peu plus la démocratie
dans son pays
[Applaudissements]
mais comme usé par trop d'années de
combat Lola tombe malade il a un cancer
et tout le monde pense qu'il va mourir
[Musique]
il s'en sort pourtant et s'adresse
bientôt au Brésilien en pensant déjà à
un retour dans le jeu électoral
[Musique]
en 2015 la successeur de Lula est réélu
pour un deuxième mandat elle favorise
alors le lancement d'une vaste opération
anticorruption qui touche tous les
parties lavage atome lavage express
le Congrès dont de nombreux membres sont
mis en cause ne lui pardonnera pas elle
est victime d'un coup d'État
institutionnel et écarté du pouvoir
Lula se porte alors à nouveau candidat à
l'élection présidentielle et se retrouve
très vite en tête des sondages
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la droite écartée du pouvoir depuis
maintenant 14 ans va alors tenter de
retourner l'opération lavageau lavage
Express contre Lula en engageant des
poursuites judiciaires contre lui pour
corruption
et le destin s'acharne sur l'ancien
président quand sa femme Marisa
partenaire de tous les combats depuis
plus de 40 ans meurent subitement d'un
AVC en 2017
[Musique]
dévasté mais les obsèques de Marisa se
transforment malgré lui en
mythylopédique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la descente aux enfers n'est pas finie
après de multiples rebondissements Lola
est condamné en 2018 à 12 ans de prison
pour avoir prétendument accepté un
appartement en cadeau quand il était
président
les accusations tournent en boucle à la
télévision les Brésiliens doutent et
Lula accuse le coup
de feu
a été organisé comme un spectacle
que Lula soit en permanence présentée
comme un criminel
et donc les médias n'ont pas cessé de le
faire passer pour un personnage odieux
et
crimineloise
un nouveau mandat où il avait beaucoup
de chance car il avait fini ses deux
gouvernements sur une approbation très
forte et donc avec un très grand
potentiel en tant que candidats
le sort de Lula devient un enjeu
national le juge Moreau qui l'a condamné
et nommé ministre de la Justice en
remerciement des services rendus le pays
est coupé en deux les détracteurs de
Lula se réjouissent de sa condamnation
tandis que chez ses partisans beaucoup
lui conseillent d'aller se réfugier à
l'étranger pour échapper à la prison de
nombreux pays lui proposent alors
l'asile politique
[Musique]
jamais il n'a été tenté par cette
hypothèse
à cause de son respect pour le jeu
démocratique parce que Lula il sait que
le rêve secret de l'élite brésilienne et
qui sortent du jeu démocratie parce que
le jour où il sort du jeu démocratique
même quand ce jeu il est totalement
biaisé même quand ce jeu il a perdu
toute légitimité même quand ce jeu il
est devenu illégal
ce que les Lite politique veut c'est que
le lac commettre la faute soit à
l'initiative de la faute morale parce
que ce jour là il est
est donc transféré par hélicoptère de
nuit au siège de la police fédérale dans
une véritable scène de films qui réjouit
ses opposants
[Applaudissements]
sous les feux d'artifice et les pétards
il entre en prison pour 12 années et
tout le monde est persuadé qu'il y
finira sa vie
c'est sa vie qui a vire on savait qu'il
y avait un symbole politique dans cette
condamnation quelle transcendait
l'histoire individuelle de Lula et
athaniel notre propre démocratie
pour l'élection de bolsonaro en 2018
[Applaudissements]
en prison la voix est effectivement
libre pour le candidat d'extrême droite
jaillir bolsonaro un ancien militaire
élu président en 2018
[Applaudissements]
bolsonaro va mener tambour battant une
politique à l'exacte opposée de celle de
Lula la misère et la fin refont leur
apparition au Brésil la déforestation de
l'Amazonie connaît une accélération sans
précédent
le ministère de la Culture est purement
et simplement supprimé et l'on ouvre
pour les enfants pauvres des écoles
civico militaires
[Musique]
la généralisation de l'éducation
publique et gratuite jusqu'à
l'enseignement supérieur au Brésil avait
été une mesure très importante et ce
n'est pas un hasard que ce soit cela qui
soit détruit
c'est vraiment détruit c'est des
immeubles qui prennent feu des musées
publics qui prennent feu des structures
universitaires qui sont fermées ou
abandonnés et la perspective d'un
approfondissement de cette destruction
avec des coupes très importantes dans
les services publics brésiliens
le président bolsonaro va aussi
autoriser les milices privées et
libéraliser les ventes d'armes les
échauffourés sur la voie publique se
multiplient
pendant ce temps-là Lula lui croupie
toujours dans sa cellule
[Musique]
nous pensions qu'il allait perdre le
Nord qu'il allait tout perdre il a été
très triste il a passé des moments très
angoissants en prison beaucoup de gens
pensaient que ce serait la fin de sa vie
politique qu'il allait sortir pour
mettre un pyjama et vieillir quelque
part
[Musique]
mais même en prison Lula reste populaire
et ses partisans ne le lâchent pas
certains campent même devant la prison
depuis le premier jour de son
incarcération pour lui soutenir le moral
tous les jours il criait bonjour
président Lula bon après-midi président
Lula bonsoir président Lula et cela
symboliquement a été très important pour
garantir que Lula puisse continuer qu'il
puisse sortir de cette situation
et qu'il puisse continuer à représenter
le Brésil en ce moment historique que
nous vivons
d'une dimension mondiale globale être
dans cet espace son esprit était
toujours
libre toujours libre et je pense qu'il a
même
il a même
disons grandi dans cette époque à la
prison il a beaucoup lu il a beaucoup
pensé
deux événements vont servir de
détonateur pour Lula la mort qui frappe
à nouveau cette fois-ci son frère adoré
Vava aux obsèques duquel il lui est
interdit de se rendre quelque chose
d'impensable dans un pays catholique
comme le Brésil
[Musique]
et un mois plus tard la mort de son
petit-fils de 7 ans cette fois-ci il est
autorisé à sortir de sa cellule pour
aller à ses obsèques
et comme toujours avec Lula cet
événement privé se transforme en
événement politique où il va prendre une
décision
de son petit-fils il lui promet qu'il va
prouver son innocence
et que la seule façon de prouver son
innocence
le premier message qu'il m'a envoyé de
retour en prison c'est je vais sortir
d'ici je vais être candidat et le Brésil
va être heureux à nouveau
repart en prison mais dans sa tête il
repart en campagne car il est persuadé
qu'il va sortir rapidement de sa cellule
[Musique]
et effectivement en 2019 après un an et
demi passée derrière les barreaux la
plus haute juridiction du Brésil le
Tribunal suprême fédéral annule toutes
les poursuites contre lui en pointant la
partialité du juge Moreau qu'il l'a
condamné l'oula il avait de tous les
soupçons de fraude qui pesaient sur lui
et libérer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il a réussi à ce que la justice
comprenne le plus monter dont il avait
été victime
une fille il a récupéré ses droits
il a récupéré sa capacité de dialogue
avec la société brésilienne à nouveau
il a récupéré son prestige et il a
récupéré sa force politique c'est une
prise de risque qui a énorme du point de
vue de son intégrité physique et il a
réussi son pari
[Musique]
naturellement
sans avoir commis aucun crime simplement
parce qu'il croyait possible de prouver
son innocence
Lula à partir de cette résistance qui
est une résistance politique commence
également à représenter une sorte de
résistance spirituelle
représente
le de Lula devient un combat spirituel
pour soutenir la vérité car il sait que
la vérité et le fondement de la
démocratie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vérité démocratie de mots bien malmenés
cette année-là au Brésil quand le covid
s'abat sur le monde en 2020 il faut
enterrer les gens du thé jour sans
discontinuer dans tout le pays car le
président bolsonaro ne prend aucune
mesure pour protéger sa population
il y aura 700 000 morts des images qui
vont choquer tous les Brésiliens et le
monde entier
et quand un vaccin est enfin mis au
point bolsonaro appelle les Brésiliens a
continué à se réfugier dans la prière
Lula lui se fait piquer devant les
caméras et appelle tout le monde à faire
de même
le la était élu ré élu là en octobre par
un front républicain et se font
républicain innaie dans la mobilisation
pour les vaccins parce que oui il y
avait tout le Brésil démocratique
si on pouvait le mobiliser par une
question c'était être en faveur ou
contre les vaccins parce que là la ligne
elle était très claire il n'y avait pas
de personnes qui étaient contre les
vaccins
qui avait une vision d'un État
démocratique qui avait une vision de
santé publique qui avait une vision de
stabilité de responsabilité sociale
[Musique]
en 2022 Lula est donc candidat à
l'élection présidentielle pour la 7e
fois de sa vie
le covid reste un sujet important de la
campagne et une fois de plus son
histoire personnelle se confond avec
celle de son pays
ce jour là c'est sa troisième épouse
Jean-Jacques qui prend d'abord la parole
sur scène
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au président
la santé la fin l'éducation les sujets
qui avaient conduits à la première
élection de Lula il y a 20 ans sont donc
de nouveaux d'actualité
et si le tribun a perdu de sa voix il
n'a rien perdu de son talent pour
arrangler les foules
et les noirs et les noirs
[Applaudissements]
a donc été élu président du Brésil pour
la troisième fois le 30 octobre 2022
[Applaudissements]
mais de justesse à peine 51% des voix
la ligne démocratique à triompher mais
il a gagné d'acheveu
alors que va-t-il faire maintenant mais
surtout que peut-il faire
la situation n'est pas du tout la même
qu'il y a 20 ans
j'ai de la peine pour lui il a 75 ans il
n'est plus tout jeune et il va hériter
d'une terre dévastée il va devoir tout
recommencer depuis le début il va devoir
reconstruire le
brésila va conquérir plus de droits pour
les pauvres il va réussir à sortir le
Brésil de la fin il l'a déjà fait par le
passé et je crois qu'il parviendra aussi
à contrôler la progression de la
déforestation de la forêt amazonienne
le Brésil est l'une des plus grandes
économies du monde il a déjà été à la
sixième place pendant la présidence de
Lula on va réincer aujourd'hui il va se
réinsérer dans l'économie mondiale
le Brésil peut être un exemple pour le
monde dans le combat contre le
changement climatique pour la
préservation de l'environnement et pour
les énergies renouvelables c'est propre
énergie
[Musique]
au-delà de ces mesures concrètes l'enjeu
est aujourd'hui plus large pour Lula le
pays est fracturé l'ex-président
bolsonaro n'a reconnu sa défaite que du
bout des lèvres ces idées d'extrême
droite ont essaimer dans tout le pays et
c'est partisans réclament un nouveau
coup d'état
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je dirais qu'il a devant lui plus que de
battre bolsonaro c'est de battre le
bolsonarisme c'est pas seulement la
gauche contre la droite c'est vraiment
une vision de la démocratie de la
civilisation
que l'on a incarne maintenant contre une
vision
antisibilisation
anti progrès dès le monété contraire à
tous les valeurs de lumière il va faire
combien de mandats là maintenant Loula
un seul
pourquoi parce que le retour de Lula et
ça c'est le plus grand risque qu'on vit
maintenant ne peut pas être seulement
une parenthèse républicaine
dans un grand événement du populisme de
l'antipolitique a commencé à 2016 il
doit être la fermeture de cette de cette
parenthèse extrémiste qu'on a connu sous
bolsonaro et un peu soutenait avant et
l'ouverture vers quelque chose de
nouveau
et je pense que Lula il sait très bien
qu'il doit faire cette transition et
c'est pas seulement une transition c'est
de donner un destin au Brésil un destin
politique qu'un chemin pour les
prochaines générations
le destin du Brésil se retrouve donc
encore une fois entre les mains de
l'oullah quoi qu'il fasse une chose est
sûre en tout cas lui Louis iliaccio Lula
da Silva l'ancien tourneur Fraser né
dans la plus grande misère est devenue
trois fois président de l'un des plus
grands pays du monde aura eu un destin
extraordinaire
un destin dont il fut le premier artisan
le destin d'un homme qui restera dans
l'histoire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]